en una semana el presidente electo joe
biden estará listo para ser juramentado
en el capitolio en los mismos escalones
asaltados por los manifestantes pro
trump a raíz de la insurrección
multitudinaria a la alcaldesa de
washington y si está solicitando que
haya refuerzos en la seguridad tanto
antes como después del evento y pidiendo
que sean denegados los permisos para
manifestantes
y neo nuestros objetivos ahora mismo son
alentar a los estadounidenses a
participar virtualmente y proteger el
distrito de columbia de otra
insurrección violenta como las
experimentadas en el capitolio y sus
alrededores el pasado 6 de enero
apro ex las autoridades dicen que unos
seis mil miembros de la guardia nacional
ya han llegado a washington un número
que está esperado que se incrementa
hasta los 10.000 durante el fin de
semana para el miércoles 15.000 tropas
de la guardia nacional estarán
desplegadas en la capital casi el doble
de efectivos movilizados para la
juramentación de trump en 2017 el fbi ha
avisado que además está planeado que
haya manifestantes potencialmente
armados tanto en washington como en las
capitales de los 50 estados antes de la
juramentación muchos de ellos
organizados por grupos de extrema
derecha aún así va y bendice que estará
presente en el evento al aire libre como
está planeado
i
y no estoy asustado de hacer el
juramento en el exterior creo que es
realmente importante que se ponga el
verdadero foco de la detención de las
personas involucradas en la sedición la
amenaza a la vida de las personas y la
destrucción de la propiedad pública
causando grandes daños algo de lo que
son responsables
como feliz
el servicio secreto dice que se
establecerán puntos de control y
controles de seguridad además un centro
de coordinación múltiple reunirá a las
agencias de seguridad más importantes
con el fin de supervisar la
juramentación